[Musique]
comment
à
[Rires]
[Musique]
jolyane oui mais j'ai fait un petit
cadeau à billets
[Musique]
ouais bien
walla est atteint attention le milieu et
haut de gamme
[Musique]
hop
le biais se transforme bien sûr chinoise
hé oui je t'en vas pas de là moi achats
et oui et c'est de pièces regarde bien
oui une pièce deux pièces
[Musique]
à sous la table
et elles reviennent rada truc le score
va pas je suis sûr que tu es jaloux rock
ou est ce que tu m'as fait comme black
adam au nom non la ratatouille tu es
vraiment dessous de tout donne moi c'est
pierre qui voyait plus rien t'as plus
rien du tout me suis très bien dans ma
peau d'un très joli foulard pour toi on
line et faire un tour très spécial deux
pièces ou de pièces 1 de droit
combien d'un truc de pièces dans ma main
gauche je ne sais plus j'ai pu tous ceux
et combien dans la main droite
de combien tu en as tu ne sais plus du
tout regarde oui de aussi très bien
maintenant je mets ces deux pièces ou le
foulard
tu penses que j'ai triché non non non
non non ils sont bien toujours là
attention
on rit c'est formidable car regarde bien
j'ai ici maintenant les femmes nées de
pièces qui ont rejoint les eaux mais ce
n'est pas tout car garde le foulard
et oui schenk roches
c'est pour toi
[Musique]
m
on
[Musique]
à
ou pas
je
m
non
oh
toi la main
combien d'oreilles à la pâte deux
oreilles trois lapins à 6 1 6 o rehn
c'est ça eh bien regardez avec la magie
up cela change car il suffit de regarder
trois là par trois oreilles
[Musique]
ban
donc
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
il
on va
[Musique]
je
bon
e
[Musique]
m
à quai
il
[Musique]
oh
oui
et vous
[Musique]
gerin oui qu'est ce que c'est que ce
truc que j'ai mal partout spéciale avant
c'était pas tant comme truc tu veux
avoir un géorgien regarde un petit
illustré et roulé noir il est autour
d'une corde et maintenant ce qui est
invraisemblable regarde contre la
pesanteur il s'élève dans l'espace un
illustre et innovante et procès et bien
écoute si tu veux le faire je vais vous
montrer une chose que je ne fais jamais
c'est vous montre l'intérieur du tube
vol un tube transparent
c'est joli et oui c'est très joli alors
regardez ce qu'il se passe
wall a envoyé très bien mais il ya à
l'intérieur un anneau pour que vous
puissiez le vois je vais le laisser
sortir
prague - dans en fait l'accord découper
une partie est attaché à l'anneau et est
tenu en main et l'autre partie passe par
l'anneau et les coincer par un trombone
ici puisqu'il vous faut pour faire suite
aux deux trombones c'est un truc mais
oui deux morceaux de ficelle et un petit
anneau l'anneau est attaché à la ficelle
et les deux troncs ballon c'est vers la
façon suivante dans l'illustré comme
ceci voilà le trombone la ficelle passé
dans l'anneau l'anneau attaché de
l'autre côté on n'a plus qu'à fixer d'à
côté un an et ensuite vous avez vous
rendre compte
il suffira de tirer et la l'illustré
avancera vanessa a tué campe une ferme
non à la fin il a fait râler et bien
montre nos âmes ce brillant rien
ah oui capable et aider parce que tu
sais ça y est mais stop tu peux
peut-être qu'on voit mieux 1
attention c'est la croatie contre le
alberto aux attentes
c'est mon but c'est nier c'est chouette
on
[Musique]
oh
et
à
mon
[Musique]
à
mais
[Musique]
ans
ou pas
[Musique]
[Musique]
tric qu'est ce que tu vois tard très
jeune mais pas mon numéro de lanceur de
couteaux pour sa lutte aux pics tu as
une cible si harry pour lancer les
couteaux ou type de procès les couteaux
bonjour préparer en lycée général une
cible girard gérard regarder vivre à
laisser vous faire
oui c'est très amusant vous ma tâche est
un jeu naturel très lyon non non non je
suis pas d'accord vous ne me trouvais
pas très attaché au moment
nos serveurs soient solides a ajouté
prost
qu'est-ce que vous avez encore trouvé
comment transformer gérard pelote des
pinces pour que ce soit plus difficile
girard je vais me bander les yeux et moi
j'ai ouvert un bandeau de la tête aux
pieds
[Musique]
troc
à
on s'est amusé m l approche est roi
[Musique]
le braconnage
oh
[Musique]